this is Oregon in America's Pacific
Northwest it's the epicenter of an
almighty legal Rao caused by a group of
children who decided four years ago
to sue the US government over climate
change this is Kelsey Julianne the lead
plaintiff when I first got involved in
climate litigation I was 14 years old
and I didn't even know what a plaintiff
was no one thought the case known as
Juliana versus the United States would
get very far
but the government has tried and failed
to get it thrown out of court and now
it's about one central question is there
a constitutional right to a safe and
stable climate we want this right
established because we as young people
have been and are still feeling the
effects of climate destabilization in
our daily lives in our home and in our
prospect of a future and in a stable
reliable future we want our government
to act on the most pressing issue of our
time we do not want money because if we
do not act on those other things money
will be nothing trees dying in vast
numbers about three-quarters of the
forests and we're wondering what is this
going to look like the warming planet is
already impacting Jacob LaBelle's family
farm he joined the case because if it
wins the court can force the government
to tackle the climate crisis the whole
idea of this case is that the United
States government has known about
climate change and what burning fossil
fuel does to our planet and it has known
about the best science for nearly 60
years and they've continued to support
subsidize and perpetuate a fossil fuel
national energy system this is a direct
attack on the lives of the youngest and
most vulnerable citizens of this country
to me this was the period when we had a
chance to really turn things around
Julia Olson is the lawyer in charge a
timeline in her office tracing what US
governments have known and when could
this be the lever that gets pulled that
changes the course of history for the
United States I sure hope so
and that's the aim of the case it's
we're hoping for a decision that is like
the decision on ending segregation in
this country and we needed that Supreme
Court decision at that time and we need
the court to weigh in on this issue of
climate destruction that our government
is sanctioning but first they must get
to trial the Department of Justice is
arguing the case is unconstitutional and
now an appeals court is deciding if it
can proceed
the plaintiffs are waiting impatiently I
think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of the future
of this beauty around us the future of
you and me what's happening here in
Oregon is being repeated on a smaller
scale at the state level across the
country with lots of different legal
cases underway demanding action and
accountability it's a new kind of
activism - protests in the streets but
it may turn out to be just as powerful
young people finding any way they can to
fight for climate justice in America
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in Oregon